I have a pretty plain aesthetic I I
dress in plain black usually my tattoos
are how I show my personality they're
different aspects of me at different
times in my life some are just dumb
that's me and a nutshell like there
there's some meaning but a lot of it's
just
[Music]
stupid this is the only joke that I've
ever come up with in my life and it only
works as a tattoo the sort of infinity
symbol that was so popular when I was in
college they said live laugh love I
wanted to get one that said soup salad
bread sticks that's my little Olive
Garden sorority sister mash up that
nobody was asking for whatever I like
Olive Garden sorry so this is Tiny whisk
which became sort of a character on my
show oh we got a tiny tiny whisk
people really liked it when I busted out
this little whisk to give things a tiny
whisk in most chefs it's kind of like a
right of passage like there are very few
naked armed chefs out there car on the
bear I don't know how many of those are
real but like he's the vision of a chef
with tattoos Matty's t tattoos are
amazing so I think I kind of had to do
it just to fit in really people seem to
get the biggest kick out of the cilantro
tattoo I have that Jee that makes
cilantro tastes like soap unlike any
other food which I've I used to hate
Seafood for example and I taught myself
to love Seafood I can't do that with
cilantro I have a genetic aversion so I
got this tattoo it's like you know want
to understand my enemy little nod to the
fact that it tastes bad to me this is
the food arm I have different themed
arms here so this is the food arm this
is sort of film TV movie arm this is the
uh Seattle skyline from the opening
credits of Frasier I am asked maybe on a
monthly basis if I'm from Seattle I got
this before I'd ever been to Seattle so
I would always say I've never been to
Seattle why do you ask this is the
switch played from 12 Angry Men one of
my favorite scenes in all of Cinema is
when Henry Fonda he's like you sure
you've never seen a knife like this and
he just stands up takes one out sticks
it in the table it's a really cool
moment in one of my favorite movies I
wasn't planning on getting it going
through my skin like that but I went to
this shop in in Brooklyn the guy did
primarily sailor tattoos he was like you
got to get it going through your skin
like you got to have the blood and
everything coming out and I'm really
glad that he did this is a lens
refraction diagram so basically how
light enters and exits a lens it goes
down to a single point and it's inverted
I just like the way that that looked and
this was becoming my sort of film and TV
arm this uh looks like an eject button
but really it's supposed to be a frame
forward button I'm an editor and this is
the symbol for going frame by frame so
it sort of be like you know attention to
detail attention to detail that I wasn't
paying when I realized that this would
look like an eject button sideways so
this is specifically the pork and
spaghetti from the movie Chef when he
serves pasta Ida oio to Scarlet
Johansson and she swoons and it's sexy I
got this before I met John because I was
such a big fan of the movie and also
because it was at a time when my career
was really taken off and so many people
were recreating the ILO oio luckily a
few months later I met John favro who
was kind enough to give me the actual
Fork from the scene in the movie and let
me keep it it was a really incredible
moment for me so this really opened up
an incredible experience for me this I
got the year that I found my favorite
song of all time it continues to be my
favorite song it's called whole of the
Moon to this day it still makes me tear
up when I listen to it it's very special
to me over here we have a ring that my
mom made for my dad back in the '90s
before she passed away that he gave to
me when she died and I held on to it for
many many years and unfortunately I put
it in my toiletry bag the and lost my
luggage so I lost the ring luckily I had
gotten this before it was gone so I
still I'm able to com commemorate that
lovely thing that my dad gave me my
first tattoo is this guy in here this is
a very common spot to get your if you're
looking to get your first tattoo I
recommend to do it here this is a uh
symbol from New Orleans after Hurricane
Katrina that would spray paint this
symbol on the houses and this is just
information relevant to me and my
friend's trip there where we were
gutting houses and we spent our summer
working there after after Hurricane
Katrina I think it was 22 when I got
this tattoo well after I went to New
Orleans so I took 3 years to make sure I
really wanted it you know that first one
it's really hard to pull the trigger
eventually I finally did it and also
like the first one you know it creates
an itch that you can never fully scratch
so as soon as you get your first one you
want your next one so it didn't take
long I would get one at a rate of about
1 to 2 a year not with any sort of
cadence or intention I have never made
an appointment to get a tattoo I've
every single one of these I got the day
that I decided I wanted to get it I
might have had an idea but I would just
walk into the nearest reputable shop
look at somebody's work and be like
let's roll the next one I got after
after this guy was this guy this is the
original Kodak logo from 1910 or 1911
Eastman Kodak company and this is kind
of a Hometown Pride thing I'm from
Rochester home Kodak and also a reminder
to stay with the times I got a spork up
here this I got in solidarity with Josh
sheer who has a YouTube channel mythical
kitchen we were both nominated for a
streaming award board and we made a bet
the loser would have to get a tattoo of
the Winner's face on their person I won
so he got a tattoo of my face on his
lower back and as a show of I think
heroic solidarity his signature tattoo
is a spork which he has on his inner arm
and I got that up here on my bicep to
show solidarity I have one more hidden
tattoo that I forgot to show and it's in
a it's in a no no place so if you have
young children or a weak Constitution
please leave your room but it's down
here in the bathing suit area you'll see
it's a diamond the letters DP it is the
logo of a band their name is diarrhea
Planet I got that the night of their
last ever show there's a video on
YouTube you'll see me get up on stage
the lead singer waved me over and had me
sing in the mic with him and then I jump
backwards in the crowd it was my rock
star moment one of the best moments of
my life and I'd just gotten this right
beforehand and then I got to meet the
band after show them my fresh tattoo
that got beaten up when I was crowds
surfing I was uh like 30 at the time and
that will be the last time that I crowds
surf this is a um gavl people either
think that it looks like Thor's hammer
or robot penis this is the gavel from
the West wi the character that is my
namesake Oliver Bish in his first scene
he slams a tape recorder with a gabble
and this is that very
gabble we'll figured I should pay homage
to the one to whom I owe I I owe my name
this is the hot ones one that I got when
I was on hot ones this is my most recent
one this is Wagon Wheel pasta and I just
got this because a friend of mine was
getting his first tatto he wanted me to
get a tattoo with him like you know uh
solidarity and I didn't know what to get
and I was like that was my favorite
pasta shape when I was a kid let's get
Wagon Wheel pasta oh this guy this we
didn't do this guy there's a Opera
musical by Philip Glass called um
Einstein on the beach it's 5 and 1/2
hours long it ends with this soaring
filin piece and this this loud statement
of two young lovers uh in Love on a park
bench it breaks my heart every time I
listen to it and I wanted to get a
tattoo that denotes impermanence that
all things come to an end for better or
worse I couldn't think of a better
example than Einstein the on the beach
it ends in a way that was more beautiful
than you could possibly imagine so I
wanted to get something that symbolizes
that it's uh basically a fluorescent
light to being reflected on a black
floor so that's what I was trying to get
here is like the solid bar and was sort
of like trailing off unfortunately I was
holding my neck like this when she did
it and as a result now it kind of is
like a curve but I haven't covered up
any tattoos and I don't regret getting
any of the tattoos even though like I'm
not happy with the way this one looks
it's kind of sloppy it faded very
quickly and I got it because I was in a
rush I was with somebody at the time who
really didn't like tattoos and we were
fighting like you know I was like I want
to get it and they were like no and
eventually I got them to Cave so I ran
out to the first tattoo parlor that
would take me in Rochester and got this
one done way too fast and it shows it is
a reminder of where I was at that time
in life so I I I don't want to get it
covered up I don't I don't regret it
every one of these is indicative of
where I was at at a certain point in my
life there's a lot more I want to get
particularly I'd love to do something on
my hands one day when I was growing up I
was told you'll go to prison immediately
if you have a hand tattoo but now it's
like you know yeah I can I can get that
no problem if you have any ideas leave a
comment uh I'd love to know what I
should get right here something not all
my tattoos have to have meaning but that
feels like it should have some meaning
if it's going to be out there like
that